لكن ننتقل الى مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مع
مراسلنا مؤمن شرافي مؤمن اذا نتابع معك
الوضع ضعنا في صوره المستجدات تفضل
مؤمن نعم ليلى الغارات الاسرائيليه والقصف
المدفعي ايضا زاد وتيرته على مختلف
المناطق في قطاع غزه بالتزامن مع ازدياد
وتيره وضراط اشتباكات التي تخوضها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بدءا من المحور
الشرقي والشمالي من مدينه خان يونس وصولا
الى المحورين في شرق مخيم المغازي وايضا
شرق مخيم البريج وفي مدينه غزه في حيي
التفاح والدرج شرقي المدينه وايضا في
مختلف المحاور التي تشتبك بها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي تتوغل في تلك المناطق اخر هذه
الغارات هي طائره مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت
اكثر من صاروخ اتجاه مجموعه من المواطنين
على مدخل بلده بيت حانون شمالي القطاع ادت
هذه الغاره الى استشهاد عدد من
الفلسطينيين وصابت اخرين بجروح اثناء
محاولتهم الدخول الى البلده لتفقد م
منازلهم التي تعرضت للتدمير وايضا
ممتلكاتهم في تلك المنطقه اضافه الى
الغارات والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي الذي
يستهدف عددا من المناطق في مخيم جباليا
قبل قليل قصف مدفع اسرائيلي استهدف منطقه
الخلفاء داخل المخيم وهي
منطقه باتت خلال الايام الماضيه تحت نيران
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بشكل مستمر طيله
ساعات النهار والليل بالاضافه الى منطقتي
الكرامه وايضا الصفطاوي التي تخضع لحصار
اسرائيلي تجبر س من تبقى من سكان تلك
المنطقه على النزوح الى المخيم الذي يتعرض
للقصف وايضا الى مراكز الاواء في غرب
مدينه غزه في وسط قطاع غزه في وسط القطاع
تصاعدت وتيره الغارات الاسرائيليه قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف شققا سكنيه في برج مشتهى
غرب مخيم النصيرات ادت هذه الغاره الى
استشهاد طفلتين وعدد من الاصابات بالاضافه
الى وجود قصف في منطقه الزواده في مخيم
البريج تقدمت
الاليات لمسافه محدوده داخل المخيم اقتحمت
احد المدارس تابعه للانه والتي تاوي مئات
النازحين قوات الاحتلال اعتقلت الشبان
والرجال من هذه المدرسه واقتد تهم الى جهه
مجهوله وايضا بالتوازي كان هناك قصف على
المخيم ادى الى استشهاد فلسطيني ووصول عدد
من الاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وسط
القطاع هنا في خانيونس نسمع دوي قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي لا يتوقف منذ ساعات الصباح وحتى
هذه اللحظه وصل الى مجمع ناصر الطبي اكثر
من 17 شهيدا بينهم خمسه اطفال احدى هذه
الغارات الاكثر دمويه قصف منزل قرب مستشفى
الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني غرب خان يونس ادت هذه الغاره
الى استشهاد عشره فلسطينيين وايضا اصابه
اخرين بجروح مختلفه الاوضاع الانسانيه
تزداد سوءا على صعيد النازحين قوات
الاحتلال تجبر الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا
الى المنطقه الجنوبيه والتي تدعي انها
امنه تجبرهم على اخلاء المناطق تحت وطه
القصف والغارات الجويه الى باتجاه مدينه
رفح بعض النازحين وعدد من العائلات اقاموا
خياما في ارض زراعيه شمالي مدينه رفح
لاحقتهم الصواريخ الاسرائيليه وقصفت هذه
الارض الزراعيه ما ادى لاحتراق خيامهم
وسقوط عدد من الشهداء والجرحى حركه حماس
قبل قليل ناشدت وطالبت الامم المتحده
والرو على وجه التحديد بتحمل مسؤوليتها
القانونيه اتجاه مخطط والنهج الاسرائيلي
في التهجير القصري ودفع السكان النازحين
نتحدث عن اكثر من 19 900,000 فلسطيني
نزحوا من مناطقهم في مدينه غزه والشمال
باتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه وتجبرهم مره اخرى
قوات الاحتلال على اخلاء المنطقه الوسطى
باتجاه مدينه رفح وهنا الحال لا يقل سوء
ايضا عن خانيونس تطالب حماس الامم المتحده
والانو بالوقوف امام مسؤوليتها القانونيه
لمنع التهجير القصري الذي تفرضه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على الفلسطينيين
وايضا تلاحقهم بصواريخها حتى الى المناطق
التي يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها امنه في
مدينه رفح جنوبي القطاع اشكرك مؤمن شرافي
اذا من مستشفى ناصر وسننتقل الان بالاحرى
نعود الى مستشفى